discours très anti occidental très
anti-américain et puis finalement le
message gauthier s'était l'économie
russe même pas mal après les sanctions
occidentales c'était ça le message que
voulait faire passer le président russe
aujourd'hui oui notamment bien sûr et à
chaque fois que vladimir poutine parle
de la sorte et finalement chacune de ces
allocutions est empreinte de cette
volonté on ne peut pas s'empêcher de
dire de penser que vladimir poutine
prend pour des idiots son auditoire ce
que ça soit les russes ou que ça soit le
parterre de
dirigeants d'entreprises qui sont à au
forum économique de saint pétersbourg un
peu la réalité parallèle russe oui alors
c'est ça qui est intéressant si vous le
permettez je vais revenir brièvement
parce que le début de cette allocution
de cette prise de parole de vladimir
poutine était consacrée exclusivement
aux états unis hélas quand il dit par
exemple je je je cite que les états unis
veulent punir punir ceux qui ne les
états qui ne veulent pas se soumettre
on n'a pas d'exemple immédiat mais on
peut imaginer oui ce qui s'est passé par
le passé l'invasion de vie grenade la
manière dont les états unis ont muselé
dans les années 60 et 70 l'émergence de
démocraties en amérique du sud en
amérique latine certes il ya des
exemples mais qui aujourd'hui muselle le
droit à l'ukraine à la géorgie à la
moldavie d'exister deuxième exemple il
dit les états unis violent leurs propres
principes alors ça s'éteint c'est une
une ancienne de vladimir poutine parce
que souvenez vous à l'époque de gilet
jaune il avait qualifié ce mouvement à
la fois de mouvements qui prouve et la
déchéance ou l'incapacité de l'économie
occidentale à satisfaire ses citoyens 1
et 2 2d propre manifestants
2 finalement deux personnes qui étaient
kick ass et les icônes qui étaient des
des saboteurs puisqu'il avait maquillé
l'arc de triomphe ici à paris donc pour
vladimir poutine ce qui se passe en
occident est toujours dirigée au fond
vert une volonté à une déchéance
volontaire ou non que lui appelle bien
sûr de ses voeux alors pour vous disiez
aussi la question de l'économie tout va
bien oui nous avons dit il réinjecter
des liquidités dans l'économie russe
c'est vrai 120 milliards d'euros
injectés pour les prêts à long terme
notamment tout à fait c'est exact
revanche il y à toute une partie c'est
presque de l'ordre de 50 milliards qui
proviennent du commerce des
hydrocarbures c'est à dire de ceux que
paie les occidentaux donc c'est très
injection effectivement et ça c'est tout
là là là l'ambiguïté de la réaction
européenne et occidentale c'est très
injections de liquidités provient en
partie de ce que précisément les
occidentaux paix pour leur gaz pour les
hydrocarbures et qu'ils ne peuvent pas
auquel ils ne peuvent pas renoncer tout
d'un coup ça c'est clair mais alors sans
aller plus loin il ya une dernière chose
aussi qui m'a qui m'a frappé et ça c'est
très me semble-t-il très important il a
bien évidemment fait allusion au soutien
du peuple russe lequel peuple russe
effectivement par est soudé même quand
certains ont des doutes et même quand
certains essayent de résister là où
c'est très important c'est qu'il il a
fait allusion justement à ce ciment du
peuple russe et vous savez qu'en russie
les gens qui vivent bien sont assez
finalement proportionnellement assez
rare que l'immense majorité citoyens
russes sont juste à la limite de la
précarité que certains sont quasiment
dans la pauvreté et que montre-t-il que
montrent ces personnes beaucoup de ces
personnes continuent à soutenir la demir
poutine indépendamment du fait donc
qu'ils n'ont pas profité eux de ce que
poutine appelle les bienfaits que lui
aurait apporté ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que dans ce conflit et ça nous
avons beaucoup de mal en occident à le
comprendre les russes pour certains
accordent une grande valeur à ce qu'on
pourrait appeler des gratifications
symbolique c'est à dire que vladimir
poutine rehausse le niveau de la russie
redonne une fierté à la russie et ces
gens là suivent même si eux mêmes
continuent à ne pas avoir de chauffage
ou d'eau dans la région ou dans la ville
où ils habitent ils ravivent le
sentiment patriotes oui mais ce
sentiment patriotique vous voyez bien
jusqu'où il va il va jusqu'à sur le site
intéressant certains diront que c'est
une grande noblesse d'autres diront que
c'est le mouton qui suit la propagande
mais ce sentiment va jusqu'à renoncer à
ses propres exigences qui sont disons le
même minimales en russie les gens
demande pas le pérou comme on dit donc
voila voila un peu pour ce pour ce
tableau brossé c'est à dire qu'à chaque
fois qu'il a parlé des états unis on
pouvait se dire au fond c'est la manière
dont tu agis la russie et derrière ces
critiques économique il y a bien sûr la
critique idéologique vous en avez
brièvement parlé gauthier le modèle
européen est en déclin les intérêts des
peuples repères ne sont pas prises en
compte finalement c'est un peu le même
discours aussi con à côté européen le
pouvoir finalement ne représente pas le
peuple alors là aussi c'était étonnant
parce qu'ils la partie il a parlé des
régimes ou des tendances populistes en
europe comme étant un danger alors que
lui-même les favorise on connaît ses
liens avec l'extrême droite française
avec d'autres extrêmes droites
européennes et le discours qu'il tient
et celui de ses extrêmes droites c'est à
dire le les élites ne représente pas le
peuple d'ailleurs ces élites sont
décadente d'ailleurs l'occident et
décadent puisqu'il ne respecte même pas
ses propres principes et là on pourrait
être d'accord avec lui
mais encore une fois c'est la déchéance
marqué pays il ajoute que finalement en
matière de soutien à l'économie les pays
d'europe n'y arrive pas puisque
l'inflation et au qui je pense quand
même que le chiffre qu'il a avancé de
20% en europe concerne et simplement
certains pays la russie est à 16% mais
vous voyez qu'il y a cette critique de
l'occident persuadé qu'il ya une
supériorité de la russie là aussi c'est
très fort cette supériorité de la russie
elle est importante parce que dans
j'allais dire dans le l'imaginaire russe
il y as souvent l'idée que la russie
n'est jamais aussi forte jamais aussi
bonne que lorsqu'elle a le dos au mur et
au fond c'est ce que décrit vladimir
poutine et ensuite de manière
contradictoire il dit tout va bien donc
vous voyez qu'on tape sur 11 ou même de
manière contradictoire sur tous les
domaines d'une rhétorique et d'une
propagande qui pourrait être éculé et
éhonté
ne cesse pas moins de séduire une large
partie du peuple et puis aussi de
l'auditoire ici encore une fois on ne
sait pas quels sont ceux qui sont
persuadés de la pertinence des propos de
poutine
tout cas ils sont là ils applaudissent
et on oublie parfois gauthier vladimir
poutine est au pouvoir depuis 1999 il
devrait rester encore peut-être une
dizaine d'années 99 à quelques minutes
près puisque ont arrêté dans la nuit du
ton père n'est ce pas fait on se
souvient de départ de boris eltsine
c'est un calendrier tout à fait
différent c'est ça aussi un client en
toile de fond c'est que les européens se
projette peut-être sur les quatre cinq
prochaines années manuel mâcon vient
d'être réélu dans cinq ans il ne sera
plus président vladimir poutine c'est
qu'il peut jouer sur un calendrier à
plus long terme c'est vrai c'est vrai ça
fait partie de son argumentation c'est à
dire que il estime la hausse il ya des
preuves de santé bien sûr alors
justement les problèmes de santé je fais
une toute petite parenthèse on peut se
demander raisonnablement si ses
problèmes de santé qui pourraient être
justes de manière allusive distillées
par le kremlin ou par les médias russes
ne sont pas destinées en fête a donné
une petite sucettes à l'occident qui par
la grâce de dieu serait extrêmement
soulagé que vladimir poutine
disparaissent sans que nous quand je
veux dire l'occident on est le petit
doigt à lever ça serait la divine
surprise si vous me permettez
l'expression donc là il ya quelque chose
à creuser mais sur le sur ce que vous
disiez sur la question de de la russie
de son économie et de la pauvreté de la
réaction occidentale ça c'est le
discours classique c'est à dire que
vladimir poutine 10 par rapport à leurs
déclarations ils ne sont pas capables de
les assumer et une dernière chose est
sûre ça que l'europe et en étant des
quatre ans est en décadence économique
il est en décadence morale du dialogue
il a parlé des pseudo valeurs de
l'europe questions à poser à tous les
russes que pense-t-il des pseudo valeurs
du nationalisme russe ça serait
intéressant ça va être compliqué de
poser la question oui actuellement à
moscou c'est vrai merci beaucoup
gauthier pour votre analyse